theoretical physics community is the
intellectual version of seal 26 and our
underfunding of theoretical physics is a
tragedy and it's in part what causes the
community to be unspeakably beastly to
to not only each other but the outsiders
fighting over the crimes of the scrums
of this cookie that's shriveling up but
well you guys need more money you struck
the world's worst licensing deal
somebody's got to defend the theoretical
physics community because you're not
allowed to license what you've
contributed to the world and therefore
you can't you know if everybody had to
pay for every semiconductor instruction
or every URL like every email ever sent
or every print that every all the
protection that came from the hydrogen
bombs and lives that were saved to
America by being able to end the war
whatever it is it's enormous
its enormous the theoretical physics
community should never have to beg for
another dime should the ought from is no
Eric how do you actually what are you
gonna what we gonna play just wait you
call them taxpayer dollars I'm not a
physicist
those are good dollars for the most part
the extent to which the modern economy
is built on physics whether it's
communications or computation or or
protection or or or chemistry or
whatever let's be clear there physics
dollars and we had a licensing deal and
you guys Welch you the general public
wealth taxpayer Welch don't bog bug me
about your taxpayer dollars you you guys
are the beneficiaries best deal in
history shut up on the theoretical
physics community yes they're horrible
yes they're failing he not doing their
job yes they're lying to you start
paying them they will be much better
they'll still not be perfect they're
arrogant because the reason for the
arrogance I don't hear anyone else
saying anything remotely like what I'm
saying and I try to be fair
you